hello everybody my name is Nyan I'm the
black female engineer I provide content
for new and aspiring software engineers
and we are talking about a very fun
topic money money the bag the racks you
know that I don't know about
I remember about that last one actually
not that I think but but no we're
talking about Shmoney and we are talking
about what to do once you get that six
figure job one of the best benefits
about a career in Tech is the money it
often brings with it many software
Engineers data scientists people in
cyber security they will get to that six
figure Mark sometime in their early to
mid careers and so okay what do we do
once we have that now keep in mind I am
not here to tell you what you should and
should not do with your money it's your
money and I'm a finance grad because I
know the importance of money and how
personal that is to people and to me so
this is simply just some insight into
just things to consider when trying to
figure out how to maximize on this very
new gorgeous luxurious sexy perk of
yours you know you know so yeah let's
get right into it
first thing that to me to be honest
I know I just gave that Spiel back there
like I'm not gonna tell you what you
should and should not do with your money
I know I am not here to tell you what
you should and should not
this one
I don't care if you're mad at me I will
tell you to do this reward yourself what
you just did is insane that is an
amazing thing the work you put in and
the sleepless nights and the anxiety and
the stress and the fear of it all of
interviewing and promotions you did that
and I'd be damned if I let you just walk
on and continue on your day-to-day as if
you didn't just accomplish something
insane especially in this economy in
2022 and so please please reward
yourself me uh how I rewarded myself is
I bought my very first like luxury good
and that is my Versace bag it's this
very gorgeous cute like baby blue slash
like electric blue little tiny like bag
and I love it so so much it was on sale
for like 50 off
um at the store on Rodeo because I you
know I'm a Zimbabwean woman
um so so I it's hard for me to spend a
lot on like luxury goods but still that
was a reward for me think about a reward
for you either take yourself on a date
take you and your family on a vacation
take yourself leave the kids and
everything at home go on a vacation like
do something to acknowledge what you
just did because if we're not
acknowledging our wins like what's truly
truly like what's the point of it all so
yeah but don't don't go crazy though but
now this next tip I'm going to bring my
laptop out because I want to make sure
I'm getting all the facts and figures
correct because this next tip is to find
ways to minimize your tax liability in
New York City if you make one hundred
thousand dollars that's post tax comes
up to 66
888 dollars
in New York City in California a 100K
salary comes out to 68
332 this is from like deductions like
can you that's almost forty thousand
dollars and like thirty thousand dollars
like that's a lot of money so let's find
ways to minimize our tax liability three
ways you can do this is by maximizing on
your 401k contributions on your health
savings account and your flexible
savings account these are three things
that if you contribute to regularly and
like again you maximize on those
benefits it can bring your tax liability
down meaning instead of making 66
000 post hacks you could be making up in
the 70s so that's something to really
really make sure
you hone in on 401K contributions
they're phenomenal for just the
long-term benefits they provide by
maxing out on your 401k contributions
that means you're constantly
contributing the maximum amount to your
employer will like match you for so for
example where I work the company will
match you at six percent which means by
taking six percent of my income monthly
and putting it to my 401k contributions
my company automatically doubles it so
let's say six percent was like I don't
know how much it is or is let's say six
percent is a hundred dollars a month
that means if I put a hundred dollars a
month by 401K the company I work for
match the 100K so now instead of just
having 100 in my 401k in that account I
have two hundred dollars now keep in
mind let's say the 100 was my six
percent you know cut out cut off but I
was like you know what I'm gonna like
double instead and contribute two
hundred dollars the employer will still
only contribute 100 but please max out
on it because when you do this monthly
for years that's why people say oh if
you start doing this at 25 you'll retire
a millionaire that's why people say that
because it's it's true y'all like legit
so max out on your 401k and your health
savings account is flexible let's say
your insurance only covers like half of
your therapy Bill the other half you can
take from the health savings account
money you can even purchase things like
ibuprofen and things like that from the
account and it still qualifies now the
reason this is important because at
first it's like but like why do I need
to take it from the account why can't I
take it from like my own pocket the
reason this is so important is because
when you're taking money out of your own
pocket like without the account you're
taking money that's been like taxed and
it's going to be taxed again when you
purchase when you go through the health
savings account that money hasn't been
taxed so that money is worth more you
know what I mean but really make sure
you're maximizing on finding ways to
reduce that tax liability so that's
that's number two y'all I'll add more
information in the description below to
really get into yeah the nitty-gritty of
it all but number three make sure that
with each paycheck you get you pay
yourself first
pay yourself first so for me what that
looks like is before the money even hits
my checking account about 10 of it goes
to my savings account this is bi-weekly
this is because when you see the number
you get in your checking it's like oh
this is the money I have to figure out
how to continue living with for the next
two weeks you're not thinking about the
money in the savings because you never
even got to look at it now please please
please on this point make sure you open
a separate savings account in a whole
different bank because that way one
you're seeing that money less like
you're like when you open your banking
apps and everything you're not seeing
the money in your savings and that's
important because for me at least when I
see that money I think I have it and now
I start spending like I have it and we
don't want that we don't want to be
spending like we have X amount of money
and so by me putting my money in a
different savings account now I'm able
to
simply look at what's in my checking and
be like oh that's what I have and so
that's like number one number two the
reason you want it in a separate savings
account is because if you need that
money you have to like go through like
more Hoops than if the money was tied to
your current bank so because my savings
account is a whole different bank I need
to transfer money every time I like want
money from my savings and that takes
like one to like three business days
especially if it's a weekend that could
take up to three business days
especially if you're now at holidays and
um there's also a limit on how many
times you can withdraw every single
month so they really like make it so
it's like yo like you can't just take
this money out willy-nilly but with that
note make sure the savings account you
choose is something that is high yield
I'll add some resources below so you can
see which savings account would be the
best uh option for you the reason I also
recommend doing a cyber savings account
is because you earn interest on that
savings account and so like with me I
think I get like
I I don't remember but like the last
interest payment I thought was like 50
um for the month that's free money I'm
getting because I'm keeping my money in
the savings account you don't get that
with a checking account and so that's
why it's so important to get a separate
savings account
pay yourself first that's actually my
favorite tip from the book Rich Dad Poor
Dad which is a really great book for
kind of reframing your financial mind a
little bit especially if you grew up
like either lower income or like low
middle class the things that he explains
here is very much targeted for that
demographic explaining how what a lot of
us grew up hearing about money and
education that the French frame of mind
very much contributes to this person's
like earning potential and just like net
worth and so definitely recommend that
book it'll be in the bio as well then my
last tip for y'all I'm sure like I know
you've heard it thirty thousand times
but it's so important make a budget one
make a budget and for I personally kind
of like recommend a month but you can
shorten it to like two weeks for that
time period note every single thing you
spend you don't need to change your
habits right away but note every single
thing you spend if you bought Skittles
at the convenience store I want you to
note it Note Everything single thing you
spend that way you can get a very clear
idea of where your money goes each month
it's very
funny when like it's the end of the
month and now I'm like wait I thought
I'd make six figures where the hell is
my money and then I talking about all
the things I paid for and I'm like oh oh
I had I had the cool like is that
Spider-Man meme like somebody's stealing
my money and it's like who is it and
it's like ah it's me like that's yeah
that like Spider-Man meme I hope you
guys know what I'm talking about like I
said I recommend a month I don't really
recommend two months two months would be
great but like two months is just like a
lot and like y'all are very busy people
to be making six figures yo you're
pretty busy I presume and so please do
it for one month and then after that one
month then sit down and make a budget of
what things you truly truly needed that
you spent money on what things did you
really want that you spent money on what
things were an absolute waste of money
an absolute waste that you did had no
business spending this doesn't mean like
when people here budget it can kind of
turn them off because the idea is like
like oh you shouldn't spend on anything
fun no spend things on funds spend
things on designers spend things on
chilling on drinks on all the works you
know like again I'm not here to show you
how to spend your money but you need to
figure out for yourself what's most
important to spend money on and so and
again that kind of like sounds passive
aggressive
me
I find eating out on weekends very
important that's something that like I I
tried not doing that and I didn't like
it and so I have it in my budget that I
will spend x amount of money like each
weekend
towards eating out whereas like concerts
not really that important I'll like
allow myself to do like two or three
concerts
um a year but like if it's like go to a
concert or going out to eat I'll pick
going out to eat maybe you're a person
who really likes concerts or really
likes weekend getaways
figure out what your thing is and now
adjust everything else around it do you
need to now have like let's say a
different phone plan a different
Wireless plan do you need to maybe not
go in the office as much so that you
save up on gas especially in this
economy so now that you know what your
true wants are the things that will help
you have a nice enjoyable life and enjoy
your six figures what things do we need
to cut down on so that we are not
screwing ourselves up in the long term
you know what I mean like so not screw
ourselves over because the idea is like
you know you really likely have goals
you know if you're this High earner you
likely have goals like they want to buy
a house at some point you want to go on
vacation you want to maybe stop working
and become like a digital Nomad like you
maybe have these certain goals for over
the next three five ten years so let's
not screw ourselves over but let's not
have a miserable life in the meantime so
track your expenses track what you spend
money on and then use that to see what's
most important to you what things you
should cut away trim the fat a little
bit and then go from there wow those are
really bad scissors was that me doing
scissors trim the fat trim the fat wow
anyway so there you go everybody my four
insights tips just thoughts on the
things you need to do once you get that
six figure income of course these things
are things you should also do before the
six figure income but a lot of times
people like I hate it and feel like oh
you should be budgeting and someone's
making like 40K it's like yo I'm focused
on like making it to next week and two
weeks from now with this paycheck so
like get away with with that get away
from me with that you know what I mean
but at 100K hopefully we're at a better
place where we can have a little bit
more flexibility with what we choose to
spend our money on but there we go
everybody I hope you enjoyed this if you
did please give me a like below
everything that we're talking about this
because I like talking about money and
career and just goals so thank you so
much and I'll talk to you all later bye